[Music]
enhancer yourself news it's better by
Mary Merrill valve Morelle from Estonia
that's a stupid name from a stupid place
all right Barton versus tonyia we
formally apologize to Estonia I am very
sorry Estonia here I'll join you with
that and that's why you should drink sip
I like Estonia where is Estonia
Eastern Europe's by Russia the bishop
who led aretha franklin's funeral has
apologized after being accused of
groping ariana grande i saw this [ __ ] it
was really weird
the bishop groped her bishop big in a
public yeah that's on TV video got some
business on you old hold a girl like
this yeah his hand was like here where
usually people do this yeah his hands
underarm - yeah and then it kept like I
wanna seems like squeezing her side sick
catholic technique they teach you it
bible stuff it was real perv [ __ ] that
he just couldn't resist yeah probably
quit doing his thing you had he had two
minds while he was like only opportunity
Christian what bishop because he's a
Catholic anyway well bishops are
Catholic well I just searched mrs.
Christian I don't know maybe there's
some Christian groups that call him like
Bishop like he's a pimp but he's also
like a pastor I'm gonna show you the
photos okay
the bishop here in an Ariana Grande and
so you book is Jesse Jackson side-eyeing
that whole [ __ ] thing going down and
Bill Clinton's checking out her ass too
yeah oh yeah I saw hella memes a bird
dog in that [ __ ] another thing I want to
mention is that a lot of people weren't
really talking about this they were
talking about the fact that she was such
a short dress yeah she was a support
she's not asking for guys good for you
even work something like that no no no
not want to touch it for men yeah yeah
never blame the victim alright that's
victim shaming bro I'm Christian like
where's the video cuz I was like that
doesn't look like too much grabbing I
know I was like this is you gotta yeah
yo [ __ ]
he's clawing it - he would he went
through like this like this I've got to
apologize
get the meat on the car yes creepy yeah
you are old at 16
when I saw ariana grande on the program
I thought that was a new something at
Taco Bell
well let me give you all your respect
did y'all enjoy this icon she's an icon
herself come on city get the tea he's
clearly uncomfortable yeah everyone
saying okay just to examine all angles
yes please is it possible like you can
feel her losing her balance
she's just making her shoulder then not
just possible bark but probable yeah cuz
I we don't know his jujitsu background
right so he might be cupping the lap to
make sure oh my
yeah so he's like he's cupping that all
watch protector and pharmacy you just
grab it control it's way better to do
this and go like this that is so we move
and risk you falling all the oven then
if you grab them that's just crappy if a
woman is falling over on a train
platform yeah and you grab on while you
save her life you're still a hero weird
cuz like just holding any girl that
you're not tight with like this is
already too close like the first moment
they met and it should be like this or
this like what they should be under
God's oh no type of thing that's why I
didn't get how his hand was here and not
here exactly yeah you don't know her
like what's so friendly a familiar you
can get under the armpit like that in
the church we are all brothers and
sisters don't understand I don't hold
any sister that way people do it so you
hole your sister like that I know you
touches that how your you and your
sister do it of course I do yeah
what's more of a crime as is shirt where
do you find a red shirt with the white
collar so true doesn't he put the
colored thing on how does he yes that's
a very offensive colors I don't know but
the point is that when every year dude
you could clearly see how uncomfortable
she is and a lot of people were calling
out you know for him to apologize I
think she was just falling like she was
out of breath he's trying to get away
from me away so hug me that way if I'm
comfortable then I'll be in it right
yeah but if I'm not that I'm clearly
trying to separate myself I know when
they laugh she was trying to brush off
oh damn
so he's in big trouble now you better be
that's disgusting well he did like
publicly apologize did he acknowledge
that he was trying to cope with it he
knows what he said it would never be my
intention to touch any woman's breast
maybe I crossed the border maybe I was
too friendly or familiar but again I
apologize that's weird
he made a Taco Bell shitty apology and
then he yes he did make a Taco Bell
reference and they handed it oh yeah did
you hear what she was a good yeah he
said it in this video
he said ariana grande I thought that was
I menu on a Taco Bell item or something
like that there was a funeral weird joke
for a funeral yeah I know it was a Rita
Franklin's funeral I hired this guy and
why yes the family did he ended up
apologizing he's like I personally and
sincerely apologize to Ariana and her
fans into the whole Hispanic community
when you're doing a program for nine
hours you try to keep it Lively you try
to insert some jokes here and there
those are the bad jokes to try to grab a
tittie every time you can I also feel
like Bill Clinton's eyes did more damage
in his hands did dull Bill Clinton was
lighting that thing up from behind I
never had like x-ray vision like
Superman lasers out of his eyes oh my
god he didn't have laser eyes young-sam
I don't think she'd be here today yeah
Bill Clinton was trying to [ __ ] melt
the clothes off ariana grande dude she
could be his great-granddaughter
it's funny because it's not even a
mystery of what a [ __ ] Pervin
womanizer Bill Clinton is but it's part
of what we all love about it's kinda
comical how bad it is it's like pervy
grandpa yeah like my grandpa used to try
to kiss all of my girlfriends
let's all like every time Oh Oh would
you ever done anything absolutely not
you know why it was funny because it was
funny as [ __ ] Warren your girlfriend's
at least always I was like my grandpa
will probably kiss you and all that
sweet righteous that's amazing say
goodbye or like just like mom Michael Oh
like that
Miller kissing man on the lips no no no
only only women only young women yes
but then my grandma yeah love you Grammy
kisses me on the lips all the time well
that's different do you think that's
weird do you think I'm gonna kiss your
kids on the lips or no yeah well for as
long as I can use you're used to kissing
like family murders on the lips sure
yeah I used to kiss Isaac as a baby yeah
well then milder you guys I'm like I
tried kissing tike on the lips it feels
kind of funny yeah I don't really do it
that much well I did it since he was a
baby baby yeah me too that's why I
started a be there just call funny I'm
gonna spoon my kids till they're 60
years old are you gonna kiss him on the
lips
no on the forehead not even the cheek
you cold-hearted bastard no that's even
sweeter though the forehead sweeter
because I smother my face I kiss him
here in his neck like all over his
weight he has so much kissing ground
he's so cute big cheeks it's like
kissing a mochi he's so soft the
question is did Ariane a response yeah
that's a great question what was she
like yo I felt it in this sucked or was
she like in the moment I was really
uncomfortable but maybe I didn't even
feel anything like it's dangerous for
her because if she apologized I mean if
she forgives him then a lot of women
that have been pitchforks um I guess
harassed or whatever wall won't turn on
her but if she doesn't then it's been
it's a bad look on her like I don't know
why she has to forgive him like it's
like why do people need this for what is
it this forgiveness [ __ ] where it's like
somebody groped you at a thing and you
gotta forgive the guy now and he didn't
even give a good apology really you have
to forgive them now well that's kind of
like what's good PR that's kind of good
PR right it's like oh it's good to go
out there because it shows that you're a
Bollywood but [ __ ] that [ __ ] I don't
know why people think that that's such
an important step in heard that of
people forgiving other people well maybe
maybe it's what my upbringing was worth
like maybe I'm not meant to be famous at
all
cuz I don't think I would ever publicly
be like yeah I forgive this person if I
don't mean either but but you know what
you don't want to talk about where
they're always in an interview it's like
how do you forgive in this person's for
the same thing you know I mean and it's
like yeah we're cool now or whatever
I'll talk about ya cuz you can't say
[ __ ] no I'm a enemies for life
[ __ ] I'm gonna kill that exactly
great that would be but people that's
not cool
right just do it a hundred percent
because that's the opposite that I don't
wanna sound petty right oh I forgive
them man it'll be so great and then if
they died three years later it's like
they'll never think of me that's amazing
I hate when people are saying like you
know you should forgive them because
it's better for your own well-being has
nothing to do with them it's insane and
I'm like well I want to be angry I don't
want it for you of them [ __ ] that I'm
holding on I think it's a Christian
thing right like you're supposed to
forgive and and and kind of like move
move on and love them and stuff like
that maybe it's a moral thing that that
you're wrong to me I'm coming back at
you dude you'll see maybe not now but
your life will be ruined
that's true somebody [ __ ] clawed my
principal you took it one up I am very
vengeful yeah it's fun if I get my Teddy
Claud I don't know if I could publicly
forgive them as far as I know like you
took a piece of ice I think her
representatives but she hasn't given a
comment it's crazy that he would do that
in public right if you're being
broadcasted and you're the center of
attention
dude that's so crazy nine hours though
on camera I don't think you remember all
right is there a chance though we're
like you know sometimes guys being guys
we're stupid as [ __ ]
and we're unaware of where like things
are I think so and we just act without
thinking guys always know where titties
are always always always we know where
butts are always but that [ __ ] is
sometimes we're just not thinking we're
just on autopilot and we do stupid and I
think that's what a lot of people have a
problem with that that fact like you're
unaware of what are your to gain up
don't let him go get him right now
we want you know a lot before I probably
not an excuse I'm just saying like that
happens a lot I've had a lot of
encounters with guys and and I've yet to
encounter someone that like did it on
accident and not like not act like it
was an accident
do you know what I mean what do you mean
if they ever grazed her do something
like oh [ __ ] and then like they make it
a big deal like my bad you know yeah and
when they're intentionally doing it like
girls can tell yeah you know immediately
doing they're doing it in taken pervert
yeah like I've yet to meet someone that
like touched my boob or whatever because
they're not thinking clearly or
something's going on I mean yeah exactly
well we're never gonna give you that
extra tight hug and you know what there
Dino what the [ __ ] they're doing there's
a difference between like a nice doing
like they feel that you're cold there's
not they're pressing their boobs against
their chest yeah I hate that [ __ ] yeah
difference you don't feel good unless
through my hands okay for you that's
true I don't get any satisfaction from
this yeah well press two so I know who
the pressors are so if I have to
interact I'll just do like this anything
I rather hug the girl from the back and
black or really nice to meet you
and then go like this cuz you could rub
your dick on her violin does that that's
true a lot of people do that I hate
behind yeah that's true and then if
girls like you they'll arch their butt
into you if you pick up on aggro in a
club or you dancing I look yep that's
just like yeah yeah yeah but guys always
know this [ __ ] man me break [ __ ] yeah so
I try to be a shallow hugger I try to be
a decent Goodman I try to I try to just
be a guy with a good decent hugger I
don't know but I know you pretty well
but also if you do the limp arm hug
you'll be known as the guy that sucks
that hook exactly it is really good at
hugs
yeah David very good like a man he
presses the arms instead of the chest
yeah yeah you don't yeah exactly
what if you press them is that weird to
like
people that way a good story sex life
Challis not weird me
nice to meet you Ariana Grande is
absolutely press the hip then talk to
her representatives next day whatever
[Music]